now it's time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(cheering)
So this is a very cool thing
that I'm excited
to report to you.
The new movie
Office Christmas Party
is in theaters right now,
and the cast features
some @midnight favorites.
Take a look.
(grunts)
Why do you do this to yourself?
You know I took nine years
of Krav Maga.
-Carol...
-(Carol grunts)
-You know, he's turning blue.
-Yeah.
-Our family, you got to tap out.
-(snorting, choking)
Tap out. Tap out.
-(gasping breaths)
-Oh, God.
-All right, so...
-(applause)
This is what's fun about this.
We're teaming up with this movie
for some very,
very awesome things.
For every tweet tagged
in tonight's #HashtagWar,
@midnight and Office Christmas
Party will donate one dollar,
up to $30,000, to St. Jude
Children's Research Hospital,
-so it's a very cool thing.
-(cheering)
See, I'm a Memphis boy, uh...
born in Louisville,
raised in Memphis--
uh, St. Jude was
our local charity
and my dad's favorite charity
and one
of my favorite charities,
and they do amazing work, uh,
to understand, treat
and defeat childhood cancer.
Plus, they freely share
every discovery they make
so that doctors and scientists
worldwide
can save
thousands more children.
And all of you
playing along tonight
will send them real money
that can be put to good use.
So... pull out your phones,
make the world a better place
with tonight's hashtag
#ChristmasIn3Words.
-#ChristmasIn3Words.
-(cheering, applause)
Examples might be--
Presents, presents, presents;
and Creepy coworker mistletoe.
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
-Erica Rhodes.
-Eggnog flavored everything.
Yes, points.
-Ali.
-Secret Santa sucks.
-(laughter)
-All right, points.
-Nate.
-No presents, Jew.
-All right, points.
-(laughter)
Thank you for helping out
St. Jude Research, uh...
Thanks. Erica Rhodes.
-Uh, getting really fat.
-All right, points.
-Nate.
-Chinese food, Jew.
-Points.
-(laughter)
-Ali.
-(bleep), underwear again?
-Points.
-(laughter)
-Nate.
-Mistletoe above crotch.
-Points.
-(laughter)
-Erica.
-Please be over.
-Points.
-(laughter)
-Nate.
-Mistletoe above butthole.
-Points.
-(laughter)
-Ali.
-Who bought this?